la directive s'adressait à plus d'une
vingtaine de hauts gradés
elle venait du chef d'état major qui
suggérait d'ignorer certaines
recommandations d'un rapport explosif à
venir sur les inconduites sexuels au
sein des forces un problème systémique
propice aux incidents graves
un climat hostile aux femmes donc on
refuse de changer quoi que ce soit la
réponse du premier ministre
c'était dans ma défense recommandations
pourtant le jour de la présentation du
rapport accablant de la juge deschamps
la défense nationale accueillie avec
réserve la plupart des recommandations
le chef d'état-major n'était pas prêt à
donner le feu vert à la principale celle
de créer un bureau indépendant chargé de
recevoir les plaintes et d'offrir du
soutien aux victimes
nous prendrons mais n'a le temps
d'approfondir les recherches
ces réserves avaient été exprimées
beaucoup plus clairement à son équipe
quelques semaines plus tôt voici ce qu'a
indiqué le général lance dans cette
directive à des hauts gradés les
autorités actuelles chargé du système d'
enquêtes et de justice en cas
d'inconduite sexuelle demeureront les
mêmes
ça me surprend porte mais ça me choque
le colonel à la retraite michel drapeau
est un avocat qui représente plusieurs
plaignantes ont sauvé la vie des gens et
moi je vois ces jeunes femmes là et
moins jeunes au cabinet de ce que ces
gens là sont en faillite une terre qui
est probablement déraisonnable mais ils
ont peur pas seulement de l'assaut
qu'ils ont été victimes
ils ont peur des représailles qui vont
être prises
de là l'importance d'un centre
indépendant pour accueillir les victimes
est resté totalement silencieux or les
critiques et la pression des dernières
heures semble avoir fait bouger les
choses
ils vont mettre en vigueur les
recommandations du ray pas et nous
n'accepterons jamais la question
sexuelle dans les forces canadiennes
armes et toute la journée le
gouvernement a cherché à désamorcer la
crise si bien que le chef d'état-major
tendance 'on a dû se rallier
dans une déclaration écrite il appuie
maintenant formellement la mise sur pied
d'une instance
dépendante pour recevoir et traiter les
plaintes d'inconduite sexuelle au sein
des forces ici marc godbout radio canada
à ottawa